hello I'm dr. Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to today's
film is a very tragic case it is a sad
movie there's under the delusion that is
in fact funny charming whimsical and
filled with a lot of heart the reality
is there's a vile vomit-inducing shift
fest that should never be seen by man
the name of this movie is simply drop
dead friend
what a depressing case this is this
movie doesn't know if it wants to be for
adults children or the mentally
handicapped it is unpleasant unfunny and
quite frankly unwatchable whatever it
symptoms you may ask well let's take a
closer look we start off with a girl
having a fairy tale write to her by her
mother of course
how do you know she was a good little
girl if she had been naughty the prince
would have run away what a pile of shit
well we're off to a good start as we
could to our credits that surprisingly
are written in crap we see that this
movie stars but we big kids before we do
that chick from gremlins and it's
accompanied by Rik Mayall my all maybe
all that guy from The Young Ones
and is directed by oh fuck let's just
jump to the movie we could to a mere 21
years later as we see the girl has grown
up into an insecure woman named
Elizabeth this hilarious comedy pulls
all the comedic stunts like having her
husband be an adulterer having him leave
her having someone steal her purse a
totally different person steal her car
resulting in her being late to work and
ending up losing her job you're fired
but that's nothing wait till she finds
out that her cousin burned to death in a
fire in that shirt so while leaving her
job she comes across an old childhood
friend named Mickey who somehow
recognizes her as an adult just an
identity fewer kids even little kids
don't you remember what you did to my
grandmother didn't do anything to your
grandma he said the same thing back then
you said that friend did it
[Music]
drop dead Fred you know I used to
pretend I wait a minute
what is up with that face that's the
horse that just passed gasps walk ok
ladies if you want your man to stop
looking at that chick from gremlins just
get him a poster of this dog so they
take a stroll down exposition Street and
she comes across her close friend named
Janie played by Carrie Fisher now I want
you to do some affirmations for me Janie
come on just do it
repeat after me I don't need a man to
complete my life I don't need a man to
complete my life uh no offense but I
wouldn't take any self-help advice from
Carrie Fisher have you seen the cover of
her book so Elizabeth is overbearing
mother comes in and forces her to stay
at her house why because he's
overbearing not logical I made up your
bed oh oh that's all you say to me is oh
thank you mother
that's a good girl too much pink
so she falls asleep in her old bed it
turns out mommy built her room with a
flux capacitor as she goes back in time
and remembers when she was a child
[Music]
oh my god pretty burgers out for revenge
that's nothing you should see the
deleted scene
no it's not Freddy Krueger but out of an
old jack-in-the-box something even born
Wicked This Way Comes annoying British
humor you're even uglier please tell me
that's not the performance you're going
with oh wow this person needs to die who
put that there something you know
there's a thin line between funny and
god-awful a horrendous luckily he comes
nowhere near that line he's just got
awfully horrendous have you realized
that she's taking this crazy madman in
her house just a little too well how
about accents all this that's right
mother socks I have a better idea let's
play game then how about hide-and-seek
you are the anus of tamina call after
I'm gonna hide the place thing you'll
never ever find me so she tricks him
into going away as her mother is not
pleased with what she finds the next
morning I didn't want anybody to walk on
my carpet yeah I know what he described
as dog mess but unfortunately the
devil's ball sack appears for more high
levity is it yes Batman
what do you get when two talented actors
are given a script written by a horse's
proteome this is a lovely day for
scenery is wonderful oh hey there's even
more background
true maybe this is faking that we could
drive it back to a hot and now you know
where the whole budget for this movie
went into that one stupid effect was it
worth it though
was it yeah I remember the last time I
laughed at my mom's couch what did you
say to me she told you to piss off what
are you deaf so if you haven't guessed
yet Elizabeth is the only one who can
see her imaginary friend which would
suggest that she's absolutely insane but
the movie suggests that fred is there to
help her as you can plainly see in
psychological hewing scenes like this
one you've never helped me excuse me
yes I have did so if this is
psychological healing the Michael Myers
is the poster child for mental health so
after he gets run over by a 1940's fire
truck we have another flashback to
Elizabeth's childhood but still gold and
will steal silver and we'll steal jewels
and we'll hide them all in a place where
no one will ever find them okay
this child has some serious mental
health issues birth date Fred isn't a
charming figment of her imagination he's
a psychotic repression of so dark part
of her brain so the police come and
arrest her father as we cut back to our
present-day reality and realized there
was no point to that flashback
can we talk about as little time for
that we have to get you back with
Charles and I'm the one to do it now
let's go yeah yeah I forgot to mention
that Elizabeth's entire goal through
this movie is to get her husband Charles
back which is also batshit crazy I mean
this is the guy who said the best thing
is for me to go go and live with
Annabella and I couldn't help myself
I've been smitten by
Anabella I've been bewitched by her so
why is she trying to get him back why
are all her friends and family
encouraging her to get him back
she may be insecure but I don't think
she'll have a problem finding another
guy you know unless he makes this face
so turns out that Charles has sent her a
letter saying he wants to get back
together but who should show up at the
meeting spot I just want a problem
Charles isn't coming what do you mean I
read the note he is so delightful it's
like having a stand-up comedian at the
Holocaust
what's the special about him why he
sends me flowers brings me wine she'd
send me says how he never wants to be
around me oh hey it's reality yes so she
goes to Carrie Fisher's houseboat
because people in movies always for some
reason have houseboats and she asks if
she can spend the night because she's
afraid of her imaginary friend this
shirt doesn't even bat an eye at this
and says okay so his picture goes to
work the next day
Elizabeth swears that she sees Charles
on a boat and decides she wants to
follow well as stupid as this scenario
is at least we don't deal with that of
Mad Max like he did so he comes aboard
just as the bastard child and Captain
Crunch and Lucky Charms as they tried to
chase after Charles boat
the fishes
yeah where are we on the annoy a meter
anyway mmm mmm we've passed Edward from
Twilight the racist robots from
Transformers - which means we're right
between Chris Tucker and Jar Jar Binks
that's quite an accomplishment movie
that's quite an accomplishment shoot
yourself so we see that Fred sinks the
houseboat as Elizabeth has to tell
Fisher that she's lost everything that
she knows well remember your house yeah
that is the wrong reaction you don't act
like someone just got dirt on your rug
your fucking home is gone the correct
response is speech I kill you and your
goddamn crazy imaginary friend here is
the number of a mental hospital you are
dangerous but instead she actually
convinces Fisher that fred is in the
room and she believes him she fucking
loser
she actually totally believes what she's
saying I really don't how come nobody in
this movie is saying the idea for this
comedy to work is that it's fantasy
meets reality not fantasy meets batshit
craziness there is no fucking logic here
but it's okay
she needs up with that Mickey guy we saw
her there hopefully he can snap some
sense into her I'd like to know more
about the grown-up making funds okay
after mine I had to you know get back
into the whole dating okay I'm convinced
this was meant to be a horror film a
horror film about a young woman who
suffers from insanity in the form of a
psychotic serial killer I mean watch
this scene with different music and tell
me you don't get freaked out
[Music]
you
yeah but he's boogie isn't it
so finally someone has to confront her
odd behavior and snatch some sense into
her
why did you do that I'm crazy thank you
the truth finally comes out now all we
need this guy to get some psychological
help and we'll all be you're crazy in
the most wonderful way I wish I could be
like that I wish I could do those kind
of things okay nobody's well nobody's
safe
and nobody is mentally sound everyone
this movie is just fucking nuts it makes
no sense it's not funny
but that's what they're presenting to us
if any fucking rain you don't throw
spaghetti banister odd okay okay you do
it well I hope you're happy Elizabeth
you just broke a man and every meeting
of the word surely trapped if friends
brought joy and wonder into the hearts
of the world you're ruining my life
you know what I don't want an imaginary
friend anymore do you see what you're
doing to meet you see me talking to
myself you're driving me crazy huh I
thought Carrie Fisher would be in that
role
[Music]
[Applause]
so finally at the 15-minute mark
somebody takes her to see a psychiatrist
but to be fair I think everybody in this
movie should see a fucking psychiatrist
he's very good with children
but then here's a weird twist flip comes
across on their peoples imaginary
friends and apparently only he can see
them well that's odd the imaginary
friend has imaginary friends well what
does that mean is it trying to blur the
line between was abyss madness and the
possible existence of the character
maybe it's supposed to symbolize that
even madness can have madness of its own
maybe they're suggesting there's another
world outside of our reality yeah maybe
he's the only real character an
imaginary world perhaps they're saying
that crazy people have a connection on a
higher plane yeah or maybe madness
begets madness maybe it's just a pile of
shit yeah oh that's pretty shitty movie
so the doctor gives her pills to help
Fred go away as we cut to yet another
flashback but this one actually has a
point we see that after Fred and
Elizabeth destroyed the living room for
the sake of destroying the living room
her evil mother traps red and a
jack-in-the-box and that's where he's
been all these years
no I would I don't want anything to do
with it it's not right not right yeah
how dare you cure her of her violent
neuroses so when her mother and a nurse
try to you know make her sane she
escaped from her house and goes to a
party word charms it because yes she
still wants him back where is he look at
him he looks like a conehead I'm fired
this is Ben so she finds him hugs him
and then we'd odd strategy but then
again everyone this movie is a moron so
I bet it'll work I owe you look fabulous
so Dumb and Dumber are back together but
wouldn't you know it she finds out that
he still hasn't left his other girl
so you think this would be the final
straw right oh you know the answer what
and welcome to officially snapped you
didn't have much sandy to begin with but
no you don't have to deal with any part
of reality for the rest of your life
enjoy your everlasting madness why do I
see this movie ending with the line I
always depended on the kindness of
strangers yes apparently she sent her
Tim Burton land
look he's remaking something that had
black in it so I guess this world is
supposed to be in her mind where she
confronts all the things she was afraid
of before just where do you think you're
going you can't go in there
hi guys
she comes across her younger self taped
to a bed and finally frees her I mean I
know so this was all friend's attempt to
make her come to grips with her
childhood you know there was a more
subtle non-destructive way of doing that
yet jackass if together I can't get back
now but who else will almost ruin my
life so she gets Fred a hug goes back to
reality and stands up to all her fears
she even drops by to visit Mickey and
his daughter but it turns out the
babysitter is having some issues she's
made a terrible mess in the kitchen and
she expects me to believe that some
pretend friend did it he's not
[Music]
you
horrifying film my diagnosis stay away
from drop dead Fred as long as you can
it's an ugly hateful movie that doesn't
know what message they're trying to get
across who they're trying to get that
across to and what's the best way to
deliver plus the psychological
ramifications are just disturbing it's
trying to be like Alice in Wonderland
but it's more like Wonderland in Alice
it's just creepy my final conclusion
stay away from women with imaginary
friends especially ones who look like
this I'm gonna stab your friend I
remember it so you don't have
you are crazy in the most wonderful way